foreign
Florida and talk to you dear Marie
what's up Marie hi there hi there what's
up thanks for having me Dr John of
course thank you for calling what's
happening
so I've been married I've been with my
husband for 30 years married 28.
um we're you know we're younger you know
50s we had our kids early they're out of
the house but the question is so he has
anxiety he takes
um like anxiety medication but for the
most part he just snaps off like he just
yells and gets you know at me or
whatever the situation is he gets
frustrated easily
um it's been going on our entire
marriage I've just learned to push it
under the rug and figure it wasn't me it
wasn't about me and you know that he
just has anxiety issues well it's
starting to get you know it's getting to
me again and you know and I just don't
know kind of the direction we should go
we've had talks about it
um he understands
he knows his anger issues he's not
violent in any way just his tone and
he's just you know he's a big guy and
when he screams it makes you nervous you
know I want to reframe that that's
violence
and men are can be especially men women
too but especially men can be very
tactful in their use of violence what I
mean by that is they can shut your
nervous system down they can make your
whole body feel unsafe to be in your
home as though they punched you in the
face and they never lay a finger on you
and that's part of the Insidious nature
of it when he if he's screaming and
yelling he's a big guy and he's
hollering and throwing stuff and getting
mad at you for whatever
um yeah that's every bit violence that
is every bit violence
or nothing like that or he's not like
physically violent yeah the tone and the
screaming and he's just aggravated at
traffic at people at me you know just
like and it goes in waves you know some
days he's just a you know months he's
the nicest person in the world he'll do
anything for you why is he why
aggravated it's hard because he's on the
phone but
you said y'all have talked about this
why does he choose to live in misery
like this
he
I you know I'm very short but why has
that not been a lifelong I'm gonna I'm
gonna go down the rabbit hole and figure
this out because I love this woman so
much that she doesn't deserve this
right and by the way I love myself so
much I don't want to have a stroke right
I don't want to die young
right
yeah I mean verbally he says he knows he
has a problem he has anger issues he so
he tries to medicate it you know like
with the Zoloft or he's on something
different now and his own author almost
gave him no personality and then when
he's on now it's not enough and I I
think he needs some kind of therapy he
needs to go to maybe cognitive therapy
or I'll tell you right now he needs one
thousand percent needs therapy he needs
to go see somebody
one million percent you can't make him
do that though
he verbally told me he would yeah
but he still hasn't made an appointment
He's not going to he's not going to he
hasn't he said he can't get through to
anyone yeah that's nonsense he is chosen
not to in fact I'll call his bluff I'm
gonna give you three months of free
better help but at the end of this call
it's I'll give you a code for free
therapy that's they will call you back
and he will be in contact with a
therapist within 24 hours
and he can do it from his computer he
won't do it but I'm just telling you
I'll call that bluff
okay wow but he's not on the phone
the bigger thing is you
so I want I want to separate a few
things for you number one if you've ever
listened to this show I say this all the
time behavior is a language
I rarely care what people say
I want to know what they do
so he can say I know and I shouldn't be
doing this and I'm really working on it
you're not
he's not right he's he's absolutely not
because his letting his behavior is
telling you everything he needs to know
that he would rather sit in his anger
and misery than have a marriage worth
living for
he would rather feel empowered and
encapsulated in a safe little bubble
behind this anger and rage then be
exposed and vulnerable which is the only
path towards true intimacy and
connection
right that's the choice he's making so
yeah cool you though can only control
you
and so for the millions and millions of
millions of people out there who are
roommates with their husband or wife
who are just wondering every day what is
it about me why why does he not like me
why does she not like me so so deeply
you have to ask yourself those questions
what is the language that your behavior
is communicating so I'll ask you have
you been to see somebody
now it's time because you're living an
abusive marriage
have you have a group of women that you
reach out to and just and you plug in
with once a week once every two weeks
yeah I have a good Core group of friends
okay what do they say about it
well most of them are divorced they're
like yeah that's just the way this is
they're like they say the same thing
that I'm an abusive marriage you know
and I know this thing is mental abuse
physical abuse he's never cursed at me
he told me I was awful or a loser or
anything like that it doesn't matter you
know he's never used that kind of
language right you're making excuses for
it
yeah I know I am you don't need him he
doesn't need you to protect him he's
doing a great job protecting himself
right
I think in protecting him you're
actually protecting yourself because if
you actually felt
if you actually truly sat in how
freaking lonely you are
I better take your breath away
is that fair
yeah
I'm so sorry no don't be sorry I'm
heartbroken for you
yeah it's hard because I do love them
you know we are you know we're
physically attracted to each other and I
make those excuses for that and I'm like
well the times that he's good he's great
and then when he goes down that rabbit
hole like you say you know I'm like oh
there he is there's a little you know
demon showing himself and what you don't
realize maybe you realize that that's
not fair maybe you do most people don't
realizes that your body sets off to
protect you
even during the good times
so even the good times you're not fully
plugged into each other because there's
still a part of your body that would be
failing you if it wasn't on guard
it's true
and so it's like hugging somebody with
one arm
you can hug him tight but it's not all
the way
right and so I think the conversation
has to
eventually do one of two things Step One
is
um and I I don't think this is the path
but I'm never going to take this option
from somebody
um in a violent one I'll make phone
calls in this situation I can tell you
just as your friend I mean this is what
you've made peace with this is what
you've made peace with and if he just
starts yelling and you choose to leave
and go sleep in hotel until he quits
being acting like a four-year-old
um then cool I hope that's not what you
cash out and choose to live
the other the other piece is
you sitting down somewhere in a neutral
location not in your home
but somewhere
where you look across a table and you've
probably written this down in a form of
a letter so that you can read it and
because it's going to be emotional it's
gonna be heavy and you look at him and
say I'm so lonely I can't breathe and
you scare me and you've scared me for 30
years
and I'm scared in my own home and it has
to end now
more excuses either you have the courage
to leave me husband
or you have the courage to go get well
but I can't be scared and terrified in
my own home anymore by the man that I
love more than anybody else
yeah that's it that's perfect but here
hold on it's perfect but it's scary
because he might say I'm not going to
counseling it's not
you know who you married it's been this
way for 20 years whatever crap he wants
to throw
and then you have to make a hard call
the or what decision or what you're
gonna go well I tried it's cool
yeah are you going to move in with one
of your divorce friends for 30 days
I mean you're gonna have to have that
conversation
right what was what would be the next
decision or step that's up that's up to
you yeah yeah exactly that's what I mean
I'd have to come to
come to Jesus with that you know I Think
Jesus has come to you
I think the re what happened that that
that inspired this call usually
something happened
first we were on a trip and some
finally saw the real Nick
and I saw it and I was humiliated
you know the way he talked to them he
exploded on them because they were
talking about how he's driving and just
ridiculous stuff they couldn't make a
decision on a restaurant he just
yelled at everyone
and I just sat there and like a total
embarrassment sure and that you know and
it was just like the final oh my God
someone else finally saw this
he apologized later he was he he
apologized for embarrassing me but I
don't think he was embarrassed he didn't
say he was he just he was sorry that he
embarrassed me and then he felt terrible
for that and that he would do therapy he
said he would but that was two weeks ago
you know
and I haven't brought it up just letting
him
figure out that's always been your move
and he doesn't figure it out and he
won't figure it out you're right it
never will
yeah
yeah and so
you you choosing to be neutral
right on a in a burning house you you go
down in flames
you said total control of course you are
but in my personal life I've I've like
let that I'm like uh this is abuse don't
deal with it that's what it does to us
that's what it does
the number of people I've met with over
the years that are bulldogs
in their professional life
and just get beat up one side up down
the other at home
super common
because here's why
at work we feel very confident in what
we do especially as we move up the
ladder and as our business grows or our
profession our professional status grows
we feel we feel
competent we feel confident because we
have a series of little wins underneath
us that we that we stand upon I know I
can do this
at home
we are haunted by that terrifying scary
little question
do you love me
and that is a whole different skill set
that's a different part of your brain
that's a different everything and you
are terrified of the answer to that
question because you get the answer
every day y'all just don't want to own
it and the answer is he would rather
act like a child act like a baby scream
yell kick shake his baby rattle then he
would provide a safe warm home for his
wife
yeah and after 30 years I can't imagine
that level of pain
yeah
it's exhausting frustrating I have a
picture of like a dog house in my head
and he's inside it just breathing really
heavy in there kind of half asleep
and you're chained to a little stake
outside that doghouse
and you don't have to go in there but
you can't you're not letting yourself go
anywhere else
oh yeah and you've made peace out there
you're really kind when the neighbors
walk by to Pat you on the head
and you curl up sometimes a neighbor's
kid will come play with toys and really
good and you're good at sitting and
doing all the rules at work
but that breathing
that that's that growl is still there
right behind you inside that dark
doghouse
in the crazy part is is that uh chain is
not even hooked up
right it's not the mental change it is
so for whatever it's worth hear me say
this you are worth more than the life
you're living right now
he is too
and if he wants to call my show I would
love to talk to him
but he's not here so I can only talk to
you you have to go call a counselor and
saying I'm gonna go talk to somebody
you have to write down in the form of a
letter what you actually feel
I am sick and tired of being scared in
my own home
haunted and terrified by the man who I
love so much
I'm tired of you scaring our friends
I'm tired that our kids don't want to be
in this house because they don't know
what version of you they're gonna get
and most importantly I'm tired of
watching the man I love kill himself
slowly
in the nerd world we call it long tail
suicide a slow angry raged out
distracted suicide
but non-engagement can't be an option
anymore unless that's just the way
You're Gonna Roll dude I hope I hope you
look in the mirror and realize that
Marie from Orlando is worth more than
that I can't give that to you
hang on the line we're gonna hook you up
with better help and when call is Bluff
and
um I'm gonna send you a copy of building
a non-anxious life I'm also going to
send you a copy own your past change
your future I think that's a book that
you would get some great benefit about
living in traumatic situations and these
stories that keep us Chained and then
asking this scary question what are we
going to do next um so I'm gonna send
you both up I'm gonna hook you up
anything you need call me back I'll walk
with you
but this is going to take a drastic snow
globe shake-up for anything new to
happen in this marriage and I think
that's going to be up to you